Welcome to Los Angeles, the celebrity capital of the world. It's a city that conjures palm-line boulevards, crawling mansions, luxury cars. At the center of all the glitz, Hollywood. Movie stars aren't the only ones here. Star gazers are drawn here too, like paperclips to a magnet. With the Musac blaring, a handful of people on a celebrity tour peer out their van, hoping glimpse the homes of LA's rich and famous. The guide points out Gwen Stefani's house, and a clump of bushes behind which she claims is Quentin Tarantino's home. She pulls up Nyakadi Perry's compound. Do I have any Katy Perry fans aboard? Fine, your works. Okay, well here's her house. Look up to your left and you'll see the awning, the red awning. You can't really see it's red there but we are right
欢迎来到洛杉矶，世界名流之都。这是一座让人联想到棕榈树大道、错落的豪宅和豪华轿车的城市。而这一切浮华的中心，便是好莱坞。这里不仅有电影明星，追星族也被吸引到这里，就像回形针遇到磁铁一样。伴随着轰鸣的音乐，几个参加名人故居游的游客透过货运面包车向外张望，希望能瞥见洛杉矶富豪名人们的住所。导游指着格温·史蒂芬尼的房子，还有她声称是昆汀·塔伦蒂诺住所的一丛灌木。她把车停在凯蒂·佩里的大院前。我的车上有凯蒂·佩里的粉丝吗？好吧，算你们的。好吧，这是她的房子。往左上方看，你会看到遮阳篷，红色的遮阳篷。你可能看不出来那是红色的，但我们就在
beneath her house. She actually owns the entire corner here and look at her view. It's amazing isn't it? One of the tours most popular sites is the home of Kim Kardashian. Well sort of. Kanye and Kim, they needed a house to have their friends over and on the left-hand side This is the house they use rented for 12,000 a month. There's somebody right behind us I can't stop. I'm sorry about that But that is the house right there Has its own little swimming pool boy. They had some big parties too. Tours like this are big business Andrew Imordino helps manage the tour company called StarTrack.
她的房子正下方。她其实买下了这里的整个转角，看看她的视野。太棒了，不是吗？这次旅行中最受欢迎的景点之一是金·卡戴珊的家。好吧，算是吧。坎耶和金，他们需要一栋房子来招待朋友，而在左手边，这就是他们租来用的房子，每月1万2千美元。后面有人跟着我，我不能停下来。对此我很抱歉，但那栋房子就在那。它有自己的小游泳池，天哪，他们也办过盛大的派对。这样的旅行是一门大生意。安德鲁·伊莫迪诺协助管理着一家名为“星光追踪”的旅游公司。
He says not just Americans, but people from all over the world sign up for these tours. And they kind of want to just get that little feel, that little taste of what it's like to see the celebrities homes and do all the crazy stuff that you see in the magazines and the televisions. But it's more than just wanting a taste of celebrity culture. The glitz and glamour, the swimming pools, the manicured grounds, the storied homes, humans, hunger for a chance to pure into and fantasize about lives of luxury and extravagance. This extends to our political leaders too.
他说，不仅是美国人，世界各地的人都会报名参加这些旅游。他们只是想获得那种感觉，体验一下看到名人住所的滋味，并做一些你在杂志和电视上看到的那些疯狂的事情。但这不仅仅是想体验名流文化。浮华与魅力、游泳池、修剪整齐的庭院、充满传奇色彩的房子，人类内心渴望有机会一窥并幻想奢侈和奢华的生活。这也延伸到了我们的政治领袖身上。
We adore the pomp of state dinners and inaugural balls. Ladies and gentlemen, the president of the United States, President Liger, and President Liger, President Liger. We dream of what it must be like when presidents make life and death decisions for a nation. No matter how long it may take us to overcome this premeditated invasion, the American people in their righteous might will win through to absolute victory. We fantasize about what it must mean to be fabulously rich and powerful. Words can't describe how beautiful it was.
我们崇拜国宴和就职舞会的盛况。女士们先生们，美国总统，利格尔总统，还有利格尔总统，利格尔总统。我们梦想着当总统为一个国家做出生死抉择时会是什么样子。不管我们需要多长时间来克服这场蓄意的侵略，美国人民凭借其正义的力量一定会取得绝对的胜利。我们幻想成为极其富有和强大意味着什么。语言无法形容它是多么美丽。
Everything you saw was breathtaking. And we got to meet his girlfriend, Melania, who is amazing as well. Hi, hi, I'm Melania. Call it adulation, adoration, idolization. Humans are prone to suck up to the rich and powerful. But this turns out to be only one side of our psychology. On the other side, it's something entirely different. Many of us hate the rich because they are rich. We want to see the powerful topple from their pedestals. We enjoy seeing the glamorous fall and fail. The lure of celebrity tours is rivaled only by the popularity of tabloid magazines, detailing the rehab trips and broken marriages of those same celebrities.
你看到的一切都令人惊叹。我们还见到了他的女友梅拉尼娅，她也棒极了。嗨，嗨，我是梅拉尼娅。称之为奉承、崇拜、盲目崇拜。人类很容易对富有和强大的人阿谀奉承。但事实证明，这只是我们心理的一面。在另一面，则是完全不同的东西。我们中的许多人因为富人富有而恨他们。我们想看到有权势的人从基座上跌落。我们喜欢看到光鲜亮丽的人陨落和失败。名人旅行的诱惑力，仅次于八卦杂志的受欢迎程度，这些杂志详细描述了这些名人的戒毒之旅和破碎的婚姻。
If a monochist enthralled by pomp and power sits on one of our shoulders, a vengeful populist sits on the other, a populist suspicious of power, distrustful of the wealthy, eager to have the high-end mighty pulled off their pedestals. The thin line between adoring the rich and powerful and marching them to the guillotine, this week on Hidden Brain. On a pre-dawn morning, a heist occurred in Paris. Breaking news this morning, and Kim Kardashian robbed at gunpoint in Paris late last night by five men dressed as police officers. The robbers made off not only with Kim case 20-carat, emerald-cut diamond engagement ring, but other jewels and cash stodelling more than $10 million. The news media was sympathetic to Kim's ordeal.
如果一个为盛况和权力着迷的君主狂热者坐在我们的一个肩膀上，一个复仇的平民主义者就会坐在另一个肩膀上，一个对权力充满怀疑、对富人不信任、渴望将高高在上和有权有势的人拉下神坛的平民主义者。崇拜富贵权势与将他们送上断头台之间的那条细线，本周的《隐藏的大脑》。在黎明前的早晨，巴黎发生了一起抢劫案。今天早晨的突发新闻，金·卡戴珊昨晚深夜在巴黎遭遇持枪抢劫，五名假扮警察的男子实施了抢劫。劫匪不仅抢走了金价值20克拉的祖母绿切割钻石订婚戒指，还有其他珠宝和现金，总计超过1000万美元。新闻媒体对金遭遇的不幸表示同情。
A source close to Kim tells ET the mother of two is still very, very shaken up. Quote, she thought she was going to die. They put a gun to her head while they were searching the apartment. She was crying, begging them for her life. The sympathy didn't last long, especially on social media. Andrea McDonald is a communications professor who's interested in celebrity culture. There's a tweet here from the house of WTF that says,
一位接近金的消息人士告诉《今夜娱乐》，这位两个孩子的母亲仍然非常非常震惊。引述：“她以为自己要死了。他们在搜查公寓时，把枪顶在她的头上。她一直在哭，乞求他们饶她一命。”这份同情并没有持续多久，尤其是在社交媒体上。安德烈·麦克唐纳是一位对名人文化感兴趣的传播学教授。这里有一条来自“WTF之家”的推文，上面写着
quote, Kim Kardashian was held at gunpoint in a Paris hotel. Man will be charged with not pulling the trigger and saving humanity from mediocrity. Or this post. After years of desperation, Kim Kardashian finally has a reason to be in the news today. There were other snarky comments. Maybe Kim faked the robbery as a publicity stunt. Maybe she faked it so she could disappear for more plastic surgery. Where was the love, the outpouring of concern from Kim's millions of fans? Why, after a brutal robbery, did people turn on her? Andrea has a theory. Kim Kardashian is someone who has made her whole living
引述：“金·卡戴珊在巴黎的一家酒店遭遇持枪抢劫。这个人将被指控没有扣动扳机，从而拯救人类免于平庸。”或者这条帖子。“经过多年的绝望，金·卡戴珊今天终于有了一个上新闻的理由。”还有其他尖酸刻薄的评论。也许金伪造了抢劫案作为噱头。也许她伪造是为了躲起来做更多的整容手术。爱在哪里？金的数百万粉丝倾注的关切在哪里？为什么在遭受残酷抢劫后，人们却反过来攻击她？安德烈有一个理论。金·卡戴珊是一个完全靠
out of being famous and employing her fame to make money and really flaunting her success and wealth in various ways. And so when that wealth is quite literally attacked in a very confrontational and personal way, our potential empathy for her, even if we are fans of hers, may be lacking there because of our own potential envy or distaste for some of her personal presentation of wealth. In other words, as much as many of us like seeing the rich and luxurious world of Kim, we don't like the idea that she's rubbing it in our faces. And so we don't mind when she's taken down a few notches. We do the same with our political leaders. We adore the pomp and circumstance associated with
出名谋生、利用名气赚钱，并且以各种方式大肆炫耀其成功和财富的人。因此，当这种财富在非常对抗性和个人化的方式中受到字面意义上的攻击时，我们对她的潜在同情，即使我们是她的粉丝，也可能会有所欠缺，因为我们自己可能对她对财富的某些个人展示心存嫉妒或反感。换句话说，尽管我们很多人喜欢看金那富有而奢华的世界，但我们不喜欢她把这一点在我们面前炫耀的想法。因此，当她被挫挫锐气时，我们并不介意。我们对待政治领袖也是如此。我们崇拜与
high office, but we pounce at the slightest gaff. Vice President Dan Quayle was all but drawn and quartered when he urged a little boy to add an E to the spelling of the word potato. when he urged a little boy to add an E to the spelling of the word potato. And Texas Governor Rick Perry suffered a moment of forgetfulness during a presidential debate. The third agency of government, I would do away with the education, the commerce. And let's see, I can't. Sorry. Oops. That was the end of Rick Perry's role in the National Spotlight.
高位相关的盛况和礼仪，但我们会在哪怕最微小的失误时猛扑过去。副总统丹·奎尔敦促一个小男孩在单词“土豆”（potato）的拼写中加上一个E时，几乎被施以车裂之刑。当他敦促一个小男孩在单词“土豆”的拼写中加上一个E时。德克萨斯州州长里克·佩里在一次总统辩论中遭遇了健忘的时刻。政府的第三个机构，我将取消教育、商业。让我想想，我不能。抱歉。哎呀。那是里克·佩里在国家聚光灯下角色的终结。
At least until President-elect Donald Trump chose him to leave the department he couldn't remember. Energy. Governor Howard Deans 2004 campaign for President came to a crashing halt when he ended a televised speech with slightly too much enthusiasm. We're going to South Carolina and Oklahoma and Arizona and North Dakota and New Mexico. We're going to California and Texas and New York. We're going to South Dakota and Oregon and Washington and Michigan.
至少直到当选总统唐纳德·特朗普选择他去领导那个他记不住的部门。能源。霍华德·迪恩州长2004年的总统竞选在他在一次电视演讲结束时表现出稍微过多的热情时戛然而止。我们要去南卡罗来纳州、俄克拉荷马州、亚利桑那州、北达科他州和新墨西哥州。我们要去加利福尼亚州、德克萨斯州和纽约州。我们要去南达科他州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州和密歇根州。
And then we're going to Washington, DC to take back the White House. Yeah! Goodbye, Mr. Dean. You get the point. We can adore our leaders one moment and skewer them the next. Not long ago, I was watching all the way, a wonderful movie about Lyndon B. Johnson, starring actor Brian Cranston. There's one scene that stayed with me.
然后我们要去华盛顿特区夺回白宫。耶！再见，德恩先生。你懂的。我们可能上一秒崇拜我们的领袖，下一秒就严厉批评他们。不久前，我一直在观看《全方位》，这是一部关于林登·B·约翰逊的精彩电影，由演员布莱恩·克兰斯顿主演。有一个场景让我记忆犹新。
It sums up the contradictory feelings humans have toward people in power. LBJ has just been elected president. He walks through an enduring crowd and he says this to himself. Right now we're going party like there's no tomorrow. Because there's no feeling in the world happens good as winning. But the sun will come up and the night will come out. And all these smiling faces will be watching me. Wait for that one first moment of weakness.
它概括了人类对当权者产生的矛盾情感。LBJ刚刚当选总统。他走过持久的人群，对自己说了这样一番话。现在我们要像没有明天一样狂欢。因为世界上没有什么感觉能比得上胜利。但太阳会升起，夜晚会降临。所有这些笑脸都会看着我。等待那第一个软弱的时刻。
And then they will cut me like a deer. It's not a bad analogy, given that so much of our psychology was formed in the ancient past, when humans lived in small, nomadic tribes of hunter-gatherers. Some researchers believe the roots of our love-hate relationship with power lie in this evolutionary history. If we look carefully, we can still find evidence for it today in the forest of Tanzania. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. To understand the contradictory relationship that humans have with power, we need to go back
然后他们会像对付一头鹿一样把我宰了。这并不是一个糟糕的比喻，鉴于我们的许多心理都是在远古时期形成的，当时人类生活在由狩猎采集者组成的小型游牧部落中。一些研究人员认为，我们与权力的爱恨交织关系的根源就在于这段进化历史。如果我们仔细观察，今天仍然可以在坦桑尼亚的森林中找到证据。请继续收听。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。为了理解人类与权力之间矛盾的关系，我们需要回到
in time, way back, to prehistory, to our evolutionary past. One way to do this is to observe the behavior of a close relative, the chimpanzee. As a young woman, the evolutionary anthropologist Ann Pucy walked deep into the Tanzanian forest. She was there as a student assistant to the great primatologist, Jane Goodall. Anne's job was to observe and record chimpanzee behavior in the wild. Sometimes she'd watch the chimps at a feeding location loaded with bananas, other times she'd simply trail them. And following them around was pretty tough because it's, as I said, a rugged place. And so you're going up and down, you're crawling through vines, the paths, if there are paths that the chimps walk on are small
过去，很久以前，回到史前时期，回到我们的进化过去。做到这一点的方法之一是观察近亲黑猩猩的行为。作为一个年轻女性，进化人类学家安·普西深入坦桑尼亚的森林。她作为伟大灵长类动物学家珍·古道尔的学生助手来到那里。安的工作是观察和记录野生黑猩猩的行为。有时她会在装满香蕉的喂食地点观察黑猩猩，有时她只是尾随它们。跟着它们四处走动非常艰难，因为正如我所说，这是一个崎岖的地方。所以你要上上下下，你要爬过藤蔓，如果黑猩猩走的小径算是小径的话，它们很小，
and you have to often have to scramble through the vegetation. And if they didn't want to be followed, they could very easily lose you. Over time, and began to understand how the chimps engaged with each other. Chimps society is very male-dominated, the headhound show is the alpha male. He's often the center of attention. The other males will groom him, he's probably groomed more than other males are, and the same the females pay particular attention to the alpha male as well partly because they get chased around by him more. So there's certainly probably a benefit
你经常不得不穿过植被艰难跋涉。如果它们不想被跟踪，它们很容易就能甩掉你。随着时间的推移，安开始了解黑猩猩是如何彼此交往的。黑猩猩社会是由雄性主导的，掌权的是阿尔法雄猩。他通常是注意力的中心。其他雄性会为他梳理毛发，他梳理的毛发可能比其他雄性多，雌性也会特别关注阿尔法雄猩，部分原因是它们经常被他追着跑。所以，与阿尔法雄猩保持良好的关系，从它们自己的安全以及可能从中获得的支援的观点来看，对个体来说肯定是有好处的。
to individuals from having a good relationship with the alpha male from their own, you know, point of view of safety and maybe support that they may gain from him. Often the younger males appear to idolise the alpha. Some of the males I watched, especially one in particular, just followed the alpha male around, and you know, he, the alpha male would do a charging display and the little male I was watching would sort of charge along behind him and kick the same buttress of the tree. But the relationship between the alpha and others in the group is more complicated than it might first seem.
通常年轻的雄性似乎崇拜阿尔法。我观察到的一些雄性，尤其是其中一只，只是跟在阿尔法雄猩后面，你知道，阿尔法雄猩会做冲锋展示，而我观察的小雄猩也会跟着在他后面冲锋，并踢树的同一个扶壁。但阿尔法与群体中其他成员之间的关系比初看起来要复杂得多。
Christopher Bohem is a cultural anthropologist who also worked with Jane Goodall observing the chimps. Basically, if you look at the individual chimpanzees and how they behave around their superiors, it's rather ambivalent. You can see the sembivalence each time the alpha male intimidates the other chimps. He basically goes crazy.
克里斯托弗·博姆是一位文化人类学家，他也曾与珍·古道尔一起观察黑猩猩。基本上，如果你观察个别黑猩猩以及它们在优越者周围的行为，那是相当矛盾的。每当阿尔法雄猩恐吓其他黑猩猩时，你都能看到这种矛盾心理。他基本上发疯了。
He runs around there, like, all of his hair to look as big as possible. Uproots, trees, and throws them, picks up boulders, heaves them in the air, swings aggressively on fines, races around, and attacks any member of the group that doesn't show deference by going up a tree in a hurry. What Chris found interesting as he watched the chimps is what happened next. As they race up the trees, they are screaming, which is a fear of vocalization, which tells
他在那里跑来跑去，竖起所有的毛发，让自己看起来尽可能大。连根拔起树木并扔掉它们，捡起巨石，将它们抛向空中，在藤蔓上疯狂地摇摆，四处奔跑，并攻击任何没有通过迅速爬上树来表现出敬意的群体成员。克里斯在观察黑猩猩时发现有趣的是接下来发生了什么。当它们冲上树时，它们在尖叫，这是一种恐惧的发声，它告诉
the alpha male I'm scared of you, so it's also a deference. But as they get up to the top of the tree, they then stop screaming and they give another call called the Waw Bark. And a waw sounds something like this. Waw, but ever so much louder. And the waw call is one of defiance and hostility. And so once they're up in the tree tops and they know he isn't going to take the trouble to come up and punish them, they all start whying at him.
阿尔法雄猩我怕你，所以这也是一种敬意。但当它们爬到树顶时，它们就会停止尖叫，并发出了另一种叫声，叫做“汪叫”。而“汪”听起来像是这样的。汪，但是声音要大得多。而“汪”叫声是一种蔑视和敌意的呼喊。因此，一旦它们上了树顶，并且知道阿尔法不会费心上来惩罚它们，它们就开始对它大喊大叫。
And this tells him and me that they don't like what he just did, because he's basically dominated and frightened them and forced them to run up a tree when they'd rather be on the ground feeding and so on. So in terms of ambivalence, political ambivalence toward the alpha male is pretty easy to identify once you know the species well. In other words, woven into the fabric of adulation and submission are strands of defiance and rebellion.
这告诉它和我也告诉了它们，它们不喜欢它刚刚做的事，因为它基本上主宰并吓唬了它们，迫使它们逃到树上，而它们本想在地上觅食等等。因此，就矛盾心理而言，一旦你对这个物种有了很好的了解，对阿尔法雄猩的政治矛盾心理是很容易识别的。换句话说，交织在奉承和顺从之中的，是蔑视和叛逆的细丝。
Early humans seem to share the straight. Chris has studied nomadic hunter-gatherer tribes who have had almost no contact with the outside world and whose lives have changed little over thousands of years. What he found again was a deep ambivalence about the powerful. Take for example one of the most powerful members of a hunter-gathra tribe, the skilled hunter. And people love this guy, but the minute he tries to turn that meat into power, that is to keep the meat for himself and give it to his cronies and develop power that way. The group will treat him with extreme discuracy, they may criticize him. If it gets too bad, they may ostracize him. If it really gets too bad, and the guy is a real despot and is trying to
早期人类似乎也有这种特征。克里斯研究了几乎没有与外界接触且生活几千年来变化甚微的游牧狩猎采集部落。他再次发现的是对权势之人的深刻矛盾心理。以猎人采集部落中最有权势的成员之一——熟练的猎人为例。人们喜欢这家伙，但只要他试图将这些肉转化为权力，也就是把肉留给自己并分给他的亲信，以此来发展权力。群体就会对他的极度气馁进行治疗，他们可能会批评他。如果情况变得太糟糕，他们可能会排挤他。如果真的变得太糟糕，而这家伙是个地道的暴君，并且试图
basically take other people's autonomy away, they'll kill him. The great hunter is admired and revered, but if he becomes too big for his boots, he's quickly taken down. In his book, Hierarchy and the Forest, Chris concluded that early human society was marked by a remarkably egalitarianism. The roots of democracy he concluded weren't in the American Declaration of Independence or even in ancient Greece. They are woven into the DNA of human beings. Really, humans are somehow disposed to look up to those who are rich and powerful, and also to subject them to special scrutiny morally. And again, if you have a leader
剥夺其他人的自主权，他们就会杀了他。伟大的猎人在受到钦佩和崇敬的同时，如果他变得太自负，他很快就会被拉下马。在他的书《等级制度与森林》中，克里斯得出结论，早期人类社会的特点是显著的平等主义。他得出结论，民主的根源不在于《独立宣言》，甚至不在古希腊。它们交织在人类的DNA中。真的，人类不知为何倾向于仰望那些富有和强大的人，同时也对他们在道德上进行特殊的审查。同样，如果你有一个领导者，
and you're watching out carefully that he doesn't overdevelop his power, that kind of scrutiny is very important. Our contradictory attitudes about power aren't lost on the rich and powerful. It's one reason handlers work so hard to make leaders and celebrities look down to earth and humble. President Reagan was often shown in jeans and flannel shirt cutting wood on his ranch or saddling up his horses.
并且你密切关注他不让他的权力过度发展，这种审查是非常重要的。我们对权力的矛盾态度并没有在富人和权贵身上消失。这也是为什么经纪人如此努力地让领导者和名人们显得脚踏实地且谦逊的原因之一。里根总统经常被拍到穿着牛仔裤和法兰绒衬衫在他的牧场上砍柴或给马装上马鞍。
I'm not used to riding with the chest plate on him and I forget and girth up before I remember. The Kennedys went water skiing for fun and remember to bring the media along. It's a family outing in Louis Bay, Hianna Sport for the Kennedys. The president, accompanied by his kind of a blessing father, his brothers and a full compliment of children, relaxes from the cares of Washington for the day on the water. Beloved leaders are the only ones who've learned this trick. In 2011, Vogue ran a puff piece about Asma Alassad and her husband Bashar. She was the rose in the desert.
我不习惯骑着胸铠骑马，我忘了在记得之前把它勒紧。肯尼迪一家去滑水是为了好玩，并且记得带上媒体。这是肯尼迪家族在路易斯湾海亚纳斯波特的家庭出游。总统在福气满满的父亲、兄弟和一大群孩子的陪同下，在水上放松了一天，摆脱了华盛顿的烦恼。受人爱戴的领袖并不是唯一学会这个把招数的人。2011年，《Vogue》杂志刊登了一篇关于阿斯玛·阿萨德和她的丈夫巴沙尔的吹捧文章。她是沙漠中的玫瑰。
Together, they were the beautiful, down-to-earth couple deeply committed to empowering citizens in Syrian civil society. Two years later, the Assad regime used chemical weapons on its own people. Or consider this. Decades earlier, various international newspapers wrote about the domestic life of a well-known leader. Readers learned the interior spaces of his Bavarian retreat were painted in various shades of green. There was a portrait of his mother in his bedroom. He breakfasted on milk, bread, honey, oatmeal, and cheese. They talk about his vegetarianism.
他们一起是美丽、接地气的一对，深切致力于赋予叙利亚公民社会力量。两年后，阿萨德政权对自己的子民使用了化学武器。或者考虑这一点。几十年前，各种国际报纸报道了一位知名领导人的家庭生活。读者了解到，他位于巴伐利亚避暑胜地的内部空间被漆成各种色调的绿色。他的卧室里挂着他母亲的肖像。他的早餐是牛奶、面包、蜂蜜、燕麦片和奶酪。他们谈论他的素食主义。
They talk about his dogs and how much he loves his dogs, and his dogs love him. They talk about how much he loves children. The man was Adolf Hitler. In her book, Hitler at Home, the Spina Stratigacos explores how the Nazi propaganda machine created an image of Hitler as a humble man of the people at ease in nature. In 1937, the New York Times magazine featured a sympathetic glimpse of Hitler living in the mountains thinking about the destiny of his nation.
他们谈论他的狗以及他有多爱他的狗，而他的狗也多爱他。他们谈论他有多爱孩子。这个人就是阿道夫·希特勒。在她的大作《家中的希特勒》中，斯皮娜·斯特拉蒂加科斯探讨了纳粹宣传机器是如何将希特勒塑造为一个谦逊的、在大自然中感到自在的人民之子的形象的。1937年，《纽约时报杂志》特写了一幅富有同情心的画面，展示了希特勒生活在山里，思考着他国家的命运。
Shockingly, after this 1937 New York Times article, there is absolute puff piece that appears on August 20th, 1939 in the New York Times again. again and that one has absolutely no critical edge to it. It is by a woman who I haven't been able to identify who talks about the fact that Hitler loves Gooseberry Pie and how wonderful the tomatoes are on its table and it appears, you know, just less than two weeks before Hitler invades Poland. Gooseberry Pie, a photo of a waterskin in Kennedy, a president grooming his horses like a cowboy, what these images do is say, don't worry, I may be powerful, but I haven't lost touch with you. We're still connected.
令人震惊的是，在这篇1937年的《纽约时报》文章之后，1939年8月20日，《纽约时报》又出现了一篇绝对是吹捧的文章。而且那篇完全没有任何批判性。它出自一位我未能辨认身份的女性之手，她谈到了希特勒喜欢醋栗派以及他桌上的西红柿是多么美味，这篇文章出现的时间，你知道，就在希特勒入侵波兰前不到两周。醋栗派，肯尼迪玩水的照片，一个像牛仔一样打理马匹的总统，这些图像所做的是在说：别担心，我可能很强大，但我没有与你们失去联系。我们仍然相连。
We're the same. Thousands of miles from the Bavarian Alps, Taurus and Hollywood are balancing the twin impulses we have toward the rich and powerful. As the tour winds through the Hollywood hills, it comes to a stop, a new one. And whether you hit the new president or you love him, I can just tell you this, this is his house on the right hand side. This is Donald J. Trump's winter estate here in Beverly Hills right here on the right hand side, the house there. And we're going to pop the pools right there. It's the tiniest little pool. And here's the servants' quarters back here.
我们是一样的。距离巴伐利亚阿尔卑斯山数千英里之遥，好莱坞的旅游业正在平衡我们对富豪权贵双重冲动。当旅行团穿过好莱坞山时，它停了下来，一个新的站点。无论你讨厌新总统还是喜欢他，我只能告诉你这一点，这是他在右侧的房子。这是唐纳德·特朗普在贝弗利山的冬庄，就在右侧，那里的房子。我们要把池子露出来。这是一个极其微小的池子。这是后面的仆人宿舍。
Donald Trump's election has ignited the contradictory feelings we have toward the rich and powerful. To his critics, Donald Trump has broken with the precedent of modesty set by many leaders. He's rich, he's powerful, he's famous, and he flaunts it. In the language of evolutionary anthropology, he is the boastful hunter in the tribe. But to his supporters he's very much a man of the people, someone who's promised to level the playing field, a populist. In the language of evolutionary anthropology he's the skilled hunter who vows to share the meat. You can be sure of this. As the cameras flash and the motorcades go by, there will be lots of adoring smiles
唐纳德·特朗普的当选引发了我们对富豪权贵的矛盾情感。在批评者看来，唐纳德·特朗普打破了许多领导人树立的谦逊先例。他富有、有权势、有名气，而且他对此大肆炫耀。用进化人类学的话来说，他是部落里好大喜功的猎人。但对他的支持者来说，他非常接地气，是一个承诺创造公平竞争环境的平民主义者。用进化人类学的话来说，他是那个发誓要分享肉食的熟练猎人。你可以确信这一点。当闪光灯闪烁、车队驶过时，将会有许多崇拜的微笑
and concealed daggers. This week's podcast was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman and Chris Benderev. It was edited by Tara Boyle. Our team also includes Renee Clark, Raina Cohen and Chloe Connelly. We had original music this week composed by Louis Weeks and Nick Dupre. Our unsung hero today is Neil Karuth. Neil oversees a number of NPR's podcasts including Hidden Brain. He's kind, calm, very measured.
和暗藏的匕首。本周的播客由珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和克里斯·本德列夫制作。由塔拉·博伊尔剪辑。我们的团队还包括雷妮·克拉克、雷娜·科恩和克洛伊·康纳利。我们本周的原创音乐由路易斯·威克斯和尼克·迪普雷创作。我们今天的无名英雄是尼尔·卡鲁斯。尼尔监督了NPR的许多播客，包括《隐藏的大脑》。他善良、平静、非常稳重。
Thanks Neil for being a graceful leader and an enthusiastic supporter of Hidden Brain. We really appreciate it. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please tell one friend who doesn't know about Hidden Brain about our show. Tell us on social media whom you've tapped. We're always looking for new people to find our show. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢尼尔成为一位优雅的领导者和《隐藏的大脑》的热情支持者。我们非常感激。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并收听你在当地公共广播电台上我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请告诉一个不知道《隐藏的大脑》的朋友我们的节目。在社交媒体上告诉我们你安利了谁。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子来发表评论。